his sitcom on NBC's been renewed for a
second season it's called Marlon yeah
what it's about
hopefully Oh show a funny clip without
its new Nets foot Netflix movie it's
available right now is called naked and
there's much better clips in the movie
of your acts and the one we just showed
Marlon Wayans and he's like your clip
was funny I'm like rich listen I know
I'm a guest I know it look we're on a
set it looks like you're home you don't
have to lie you don't have to lie about
the clip because I know there's
something you don't have to do it and
you don't have to try and clean your
desk like I did five minutes before I
get here because it was filthy and then
you try and organize it's like trying
it's like coming to your house and
you're like hey come over for some beers
and I come over and it's a mess and
you're like trying to straighten up but
I'm like I see your poo stained
underwear right there by your bed see
don't clean that we belong now tread
mark references like that make me laugh
and here clip where you're naked at a
front desk in a hotel and then the guy
behind the desk says I don't want to see
your junk that made me laugh the word
junk that would be laughs it made you go
hmm this little Apple Avice ha ha that's
a laugh just it's it's a double ha or
what is like one single ha what counts
as a laugh moment you kept wouldn't you
get rid of all that is conscious it's a
laugh like right now you're still cool
your beer looks cool no don't swag you
know like you know you got a little swag
on you like like like it's like a like a
confident like yeah I'm bald but I'm
sexy it's kind of like louis c.k before
last week kind of swag about you you
know and so laughs you weren't gonna
laugh a laugh is oh my god I forgot I
have swag and I'd do that that's a lie
kick my heels I just gave you it that
was a genuine laugh it was even though
it was cute it wasn't even though
referring to my my my my I guess I
challenged hairline your hairline is
sexy for any woman over 43
you're actually even obvious 35 35
year-old chicks
you are hot magnet does they look at you
they see the gray and they go mmm I
could get that to settle down I'm ready
to have babies with that they look at me
I'm like 45 I'm dressed like I'm 15
they're like no he gonna hit and quit
I'm gonna do one night with him I'm
gonna do a lifetime with him
Marlon get tonight Richard gets forever
I don't know which one I don't know so
far I've been so understand if I'm
keeping score right you you you've
equated me to louis c.k no I did say you
have to be very sturdy before last week
when it started to rumblings of oh he's
in trouble came up but before that you
was like tell me you if someone said yo
you're like louis c.k hot you like thank
you
now it's like before last week's a very
important caveat right and I'm the guy
that people settle for I mean really
because you're you seem like a your
catch but you're like a forever catch
I'm like a one-night i'ma blow the bed
up and like you're gonna be like I'm
gonna think about you forever but come
be with him yeah I would never do any
project called naked I think it'd be
great and I think women over 35 would
love seeing that movie oh my god it's my
best movie like I wanna be I want to
spend the rest of my life with Richard
would that be my pitch going to sell ya
know to sell yourself to like if you got
back on a single mark easier listen babe
this Barney are in you really don't want
to be I can change your life we can
Netflix and chill the rest of our life
like you don't have to cook I'm gonna
order in you believe me that guy yeah
you win ya know I did so I have no idea
what site what type of game I really
still have Marlon you don't want to test
the market though
beautiful children beautiful children
that grown they know I'm a vest which is
wonderful and here's your hairlines not
challenged it's just as challenged as my
beard my beard is challenged like how
long does it take you to grow that beard
this is like nine months growth
I'm officially growing as hair on my
face this is it's weird like it doesn't
grow right there I know I know it
doesn't grow you have you have some you
have some spacing issues right now you
don't need you to rub it in me that I'm
a guy that people settle for yeah but
you nobody would settle for my beard my
beard look like I just escaped the fire
and lived for 16 - I got through it
Marlon Wayans here on the Rich Eisen
show what why do this this movie naked
it's based on a Swedish movie from 2000
we're basically moving from 2000 yeah
but I like the story about a guy that
has to relive the same hour over and
over again until he gives a woman his
woman the proper wedding and I just
thought that a coming-of-age story for a
guy like me I just it hit home like if I
ever was to get married I'd want to do
everything right because women don't
forget that day people why you're paying
so much for the wedding why did you do
all that why did you get down on one
knee why did you wear that suit why did
you make all your best men behave
because women why did you take every
picture why did you have the DJ play
that song why did you dance to that song
because you got to understand for the
rest of your life she's going to
remember that moment and so your sex for
the rest of your life will depend on how
good you was that day so do it perfectly
and if not you're naked if not you yeah
yeah I think every man should be naked
if they want to do it right you should
be because otherwise it's a lifetime of
mmm no we good not tonight
no I don't want to do it the same way
you didn't want to take that picture
with me over by the sunset in the beach
on our wedding day so what is important
for you on a wedding day on what just in
terms of a wedding like what would be
like something that would actually
matter to you as opposed to trying to do
it for somebody else I never thought
that far that's what crazy people like
you wedding no idea I don't know about
the wedding but my bachelor party
awesome and the divorce party roof we
are rocking what about you know if I
ever did get married it would be a
perfect wedding I think that's why I
save it because I I want to do that if I
do anything right in my life I want to
make sure I do that right
do you have any what what sports teams
you were before again yours by the way I
think this is a really cool logo but I
think you should change it what is it
why are you running like this like
Bernie Madoff no I run in my suit at the
NFL Scouting Combine every year I run
the 40-yard dash okay slowly okay I only
know one speed mark I thought this was
oh my god Rich Eisen when he drinks
coffee he has to take a poo and it's you
running to the bathroom that is not it
this looks like you it's a diuretic here
give me a shirt I just needed something
what it looks like cuz that's my running
style as a matter of fact they had to
they had to graphically change my right
leg I get it this is weird I know he
likes like someone shot you mid run are
you is like wow are you for real Oh all
day all day since I was a kid and people
asked me why do you hate the Cowboys
well I'm a Steelers fan and that doesn't
answer it for you you got to think back
to the 70s yeah and we have all those
great rivalries as we came out on top
Lynch Lynn Swann Franco Harris Steel
Curtain now
a ceiling fan forever so now your big
band Antonio Brown and yeah but benben
gotta be a little more consistent you
can't be dropping five interceptions but
that's the thing about Ben Ben love a
terrible game and then do something
great he reminds me of my shits my son
my son he'll shoot like this shot from
like half-court I'm like yo what are you
doing and it goes in I'm going that's
the way you're supposed to do it don't
listen to me son shoot half-court shot
then no no yes and yes yes with Ben yes
so you never grew up and you're from
here right are you from I'm from New
York
you're from New you I'm not from here no
okay nobody's from here okay nobody with
substance from Cali except my kids but
they're really from New York because
that is you're from I'm from I'm the
same way too you know I'm from Staten
Island that's not yours boo yeah you
never say that out loud again
you understand me you say when I say
you're from New York you go I'm from New
York I say what part you go one of the
five boroughs if I go which one close to
Brooklyn scuse me oh and that's all I
need to know
garbage Method Man was in that seat last
month would you say that to Method Man
yes I would say that to Method Man he
knows
Staten Island is not New York is Staten
Island I'd rather you say I'm from
Rikers Island than Staten Island don't
want to be there but there's only one
ferry that goes back and forth and it's
not enough to fit everybody else they
wouldn't be there every piece of garbage
a trash that the Wayans family has ever
thrown out and yes entire it was it went
to stop garbage that's why I want you
there you're growing up in Oscar the
Grouch's
jump
you're in fat Albert's junkyard when you
are from and I love people Stan I got a
lot of a couple of friends like the two
that I know from stat not really knows
anybody stat now I'm starting to feel a
little weird and itchy and I know why
your desk is a mess cuz you're from
standing out it makes you feel like
you're at home
levity live and Oxnard check out Marlon
Wayans there on November 10th oh if
you're going there tonight tonight I got
two shows tonight I'd like to shows
tomorrow and they've got me in
Harrisburg Pennsylvania in Sylvania do
you want to come to the Steelers game oh
yeah my the Intel well you're in
Harrisburg on the fifteenth and six -
pump New York anything in Pennsylvania's
got to be close
15th and 16th I'm at the comedies on the
Harrisburg there's still a couple of
tickets left so get your tickets
November 15th and 16th Comedy Zone in
Harrisburg November 18th I'm filming my
first ever standing up special for
Netflix for Netflix yeah the same place
that didn't make it there we'll be
having great clips oh that one and
that's gonna be at the MGM National
Harbor in Washington DC get your tickets
November 18th only two shows only a few
tickets left get your tickets now
lastly December 8th through 10th I'm at
the Tempe improv in Tempe Arizona
Arizona at the Tempe improv and I think
I'm in Vegas at the MGM with me and Jay
Pharoah and DeRay Davis February is
something that well 16th I want to be at
I rate it that would be great February
2nd yes I'm watching the white lady's
mouth and I'm not good at reading white
lips okay cuz they're really skinny the
right second yes Marlon Wayans on
Twitter come back anytime on I Love You
Man okay we'll be here can I steal your
cup please take take the month thank you
take the mug look this is when we got
shot and he made a cup we're back at 60
seconds with your phone calls for more
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the
doesn't show up